[Musique]
avec vous Hélène Frat bonjour Hélène
bonjour Pauline à la une de la presse le
discours du président sidjinpin d'abord
c'est il y a quelques heures pour
l'ouverture du 20e congrès du Parti
communiste chinois faisceau
2296 délégués du PCC chez Jean Ping a
présenté l'émission et les tâches pour
la Chine à l'avenir le programme d'un
pays socialiste moderne d'après de
Global Times quotidien officiel chinois
en croire le journal la modernisation
chinoise non seulement aboutirage site à
une société moderne modérément prospère
mes élargira également l'horizon de
toute la civilisation mais encore me
demanderez-vous d'après de Global Times
la pratique réussie de la modernisation
chinoise prouverait au monde entier et
de manière irréfutable qu'il existe
plusieurs voix à la modernisation la
Chine inspirant par son exemple d'autres
pays et d'autres nations à ajouter leur
propre couleur au jardin de la
civilisation humaine je cite tout aussi
enthousiaste de channely autre quotidien
officiel chinois vante lui aussi les
vertus de cette modernité à la chinoise
et le journal publie même Pauline pour
l'occasion une tribune du ministre
palestinien du Développement social
assurant que oui la Chine défend
véritablement les droits de l'homme et
que Pékin contrairement à Washington
défendent un multilatéralisme véritable
hors des frontières chinoises le
discours de Sylvin là pour le coup est
perçu avec un quiétude et notamment dans
le reste de l'Asie on déclarant que la
Chine ne renoncerait jamais à l'usage de
la force pour réunifier Taïwan chez
inping provoque de nouveau évidemment la
colère du gouvernement taïwanais dont le
porte-parole cité par de Taipe et Times
Martel que Taïwan est une nation
souveraine et indépendante et que les
Taïwan taïwanais croient en la
démocratie et la liberté de Japan Times
fait état des craintes dans la région du
risque d'un conflit autour de Taïwan
notamment à Tokyo donc ou la question de
Taïwan préoccupera un nombre croissant
d'élus en raison évidemment de la
proximité avec l'île mais aussi du
nombre de vase américaine dans le pays
en saluant par ailleurs la reprise en
main de Hong Kong le président chinois
remuent aussi évidemment la plaide le
couteau dans la plaie de ces opposants
hongkongais le site Hong Kong free
presse qui dénonce la reprise en main de
la région par le pouvoir central estime
que l'une des principales
caractéristiques de la montée en
puissance de la Chine et en particulier
depuis l'avènement de chez inping a été
son soutien grandissant envers les
régimes autoritaires à travers la
planète et notamment envers la Russie
[Musique]
sa politique répressive suscite elle
l'inquiétude de ses compatriotes d'après
la croix qui évoque des Chinois en plein
doute en particulier face à la stratégie
zéro covid du gouvernement une politique
synonyme pour eux du ralentissement
économique et de restriction étoffante
des libertés lorsque la colère gronde
notre Lacroix la tentation est grande de
réactiver les mythes d'en appeler à
l'unité pour accroître l'influence
internationale du pays ou obtenir sa
réunification mais c'est reconnaître en
creux sa fragilité